[Music]
yeah all right first question comes from
Marshall Holly's considering you're
named after Rakim one of the greatest
MCS of all time what legendary MC would
you name your child after that's a good
one that's a good one let me think let
me think
alright we'll come back to the second
question from Chris Van ash your
designer you may have heard of them the
own voice could you tell me what a
typical Friday or Saturday night out for
you was like when you were a teenager
fighting in clubs oh he went seven
Santos story one time in Santos in 2008
we went um New York City it was the
whole mob we took the train from all we
was fleet up had on this Marc Jacobs
shirt had pink on that the top at these
dingy pants cuz I was wearing teen E&G
back then and I had these Marc Jacobs
sneakers on fer you got on the black
acne pins with the blue jean jacket Nash
you had the blue jean jacket with the
same but the with the black acne pants
with the with the black tents with the
super glasses of him with the fro cuz
usually jay-z [ __ ] trying to wolf out
huh you know I'm come clean please in
the club bar II tried talking some dude
girl girl friend next thing you know he
got mad we know he she was with her
boyfriend and then he look like some
wrestler dude he's big with long hair
he's like white white white to anybody
he's like you to go Sam he kept going
crazy so G let's put him in a headlock I
snuffed him he felt anybody kicked him
we all dispersed
he said don't touch my echo went through
the main body when he got up the first
person he spot was me with the pink
shirt on so the engine started charging
ah like a matter of aging book you just
grabbed my head first thing you did we
in a [ __ ] dance floor like
fighting like females and [ __ ] like
pulling each other headship I'm biting
this [ __ ] thumb and pinky ah
going crazy us nothing him this
[ __ ] mr. Dino Molly's and
liquor we all we all leave out or
whatever you know we outside your man
gives a manager the club so he come on
buggy guy was security guards he told
ice at all of us so then we all start
getting shaken again he hop in a cab he
doesn't run down a rundown on the cab
taking off the caps of beating him up
and screaming a shot I say everybody
knew us back there Thanks
[Music]
this one's from rap Simmons oh dear
Rakim that's my guys that has the lower
right there
if you couldn't do what you were doing
now what would you do what's another
life dream of yours I wasn't doing this
to be Road you'll probably be like
interior decorators yeah we are such a
good taste I love flowers and artificial
flowers and colors and palates and [ __ ]
and like I think the core value and Fung
Shui is important so I might do that
[ __ ] if not Milo like I just wanted to
be a rapper that was it the next
question is from should meet more
awesome I say what advice do you have
for getting more creative with your
personal style what I mean you just but
the weird thing is like when we wear
stuff that suits us and not was trendy
it becomes a trend so you know about the
[ __ ] you know that's might be
confusing and I'm saying I would say
just kind of like everybody's different
everybody got like different body shapes
and whatnot so what I was saying is like
kind of like stick to with you know
fishing vessel but you feel comfortable
even if it's not in style just where
would you remember whatever you feel
cozy basically we might like my son [ __ ]
[Music]
the last question submitted from outside
people is from Andre 3000 Oh what hidden
talent do you have that only your
parents are close people no we might
have to call my mom I'm displaying
mostly all my talents I guess Angelica
well I don't know man
you're gonna make me sound world you
know concede it right now tell them on
myself I don't know what to tell you you
tell me what ahead and tell the second
question I hope let's get it
what hobby or craft would you like to be
doing that is completely outside of
music or fashion um I want to design
furniture yeah I want to design
friendship for Ashley one of the first
piece not maybe a sofa like a couch you
did design Juanita beds and I know I did
already but I want to sell much much
that was just me tested all right we're
back to rehearsal Holly okay considering
you're named after rocky I'm one of the
greatest MCS of all time one legendary
MC would you name your child after I'll
probably need my child that's to read
I shoulda said base car broke you to
read finish I go hold you I [ __ ] up
bro I said I said base car
first you got a question you can
so what is your ultimate goal
no I want to die happy like I am now but
what does happy mean like some people
think them a lot of money and be happy
in this book you smoked it
that's five we've spoken even reiji keep
it low-key leave the dance beat the
chain yoni look at okay boy stop me like
you old pal
man I do it running man GQ beat the
style
[Music]
[Music]